on this episode I'm in a salty mood
because the Jets lost
[Music]
this is
ask Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 225 of
the askgaryvee show
sid good to see you said works at
vaynermedia on my team the Jets lost I'm
not in a good mood by any stretch of the
imagination it was a devastating loss
I'm angry
Thursday we played Buffalo Bills we've
been struggling with them lately and if
we lose on Thursday literally in three
days my season's over of the only thing
that I like in life said what's the
first question
Felipe prosper hi Gary here is Prospero
from 30 to real life here in beautiful
Nishita taking my morning swim after
waking up
so my question today is how would be
your approach of creating a more
sustainable world with a media company
thank you for your answer prospering
it's an interesting question
I've been thinking a lot actually about
this over the last couple of months um
you know impact on world you know I get
a somebody somebody on whether was on my
team or my family I'm trying to think
who said this to me I don't think I
realized that getting 15 to 25 emails a
day in your inbox telling you that
you've changed one's life that um that I
was doing so it's so interesting that
people think like giving a ten thousand
dollar check to research for a disease
or to fix an animal or put up trees is a
is is the way to do it it's unbelievable
how much you know you were with me when
we were just in New York where the guys
like get a tattoo and I'm like that's
the easy part
like not missing a Jets play since 82
but I think people are very stuck
prosper on tactics over religion and
what I talk about that in business all
the time if you've been following me
you've heard that a million times but
it's how I think about a more
sustainable world meaning as a media
company as an individual
I think we take a lot of shortcuts
tweeting something to support something
is is not making an enormous impact it
can make an impact you know you
supporting something five your friends
care how you support a few a celebrity
and fifty people care but but it is
stunning how much more important action
is over little words or tactical things
so for me I think it's a day-in day-out
thing to deploy to things that matter
and I think it's a very human game I
think I like depth over with for me if I
can impact my little circle and this
whole thing the vaynernation vaynermedia
all of my inner team here I'm impacting
them on an individual basis and then
they go and impact other people it is
I'm completely confident because I've
watched it many times that the
self-esteem and confidence that I deploy
and do you think that you're a more
confident person because you've rolled
with me and you think that you maybe
deploy that on other people within your
circle that's the game so I think I
think my answer to your question is as a
media company as anything else
way too many people are looking to reach
too many go individual it's what you're
doing behind the scenes that is way more
important than when you're doing
optically for the PR version of how you
want to position yourself to the world
thanks T Rock hey what's up Gary it's
Chris not here today in the [ __ ]
pouring rain making content for my fix
gear
along the e-commerce shop my question is
lots of my friends are let's say under
18 years of age don't have credit cards
cannot take [ __ ] them online website
name my pitch to retail press if your
demo doesn't have credit cards and
that's what's stopping you from selling
direct to consumer your answer shouldn't
be how do I go to retail to go to my
consumers your answer should be how do I
get money from my demo to make my
transaction meaning whether it's venmo
or PayPal or virtual currency you know
there's a much bigger lift my man one of
the great things about the world today
is that all of us entrepreneurs can
create a Shopify account or magenta or
whatever you want to and go direct to
consumer do you know how difficult it is
to get retail distribution do you know
how much they're gonna hose you do you
know that you're gonna make 50 cents on
the dollar do you know that you're gonna
they're going to ask you for things like
trade dollars which is if you even want
to be in our story of the past for the
right do you know that if your product
doesn't sell well in the first 30 days
they discontinue it do you know that
you're going to spend 94% of your time
trying to knock on doors and get into
the retail shop instead of actually
building your community and building
your business I think that if you know I
think at the highest level so for so
many of you going back to the well
instead of fixing the sink which is an
analogy I use a lot maybe your whole
business is broken if you can't get the
money from the people that you want to
get money from right you know a lot of
people try to target like somebody pinch
me like I'm going to sell to 12 to 14
year-olds and they're going to make the
decision that's the worst zone because
that 12 to 14 is exactly when kids are
in between you know their parents buying
them everything but them not being able
to transact and so I would spend a lot
of time trying to figure out whether
what way you can collect money from them
including things like I've always
thought a fun tactic would be instead of
an Add to Cart button an alternative
button to that audience which is send
the email to your parents to buy it so
you know you've Add to Cart and you know
but there's also send the email to your
parents to buy this for and you click it
it's got like four different templates
like this
sorry one the happy one like you know
like what's the angle depending on your
parent with them a transaction link
right there
you need to hack how to get the money
direct from your consumer not how to go
down the traditional path of retail
Richard hey Keri my name is Richard
Evans filmmaker living here in Los
Angeles recently you connected with
Chase Jarvis and you humbly brag that
you're one of the first people to say
that vine is a great place for
filmmakers to grow an audience just like
if I was a filmmaker or a video person
I'd be very much paying attention to
vine and trying to figure out how to
make six-second micro videos that bring
awareness to me that leads me to Gateway
you to my youtube which lets you to
Gateway me to hiring me it's just this
evolution of opportunity is now 2016 is
vine still the best platform or is there
something different than filmmakers like
myself should be looking at thanks Gary
I'll see you in the Jets and we for ya I
mean look
thanks Richard I'm not looking forward
to the Seahawks week for though the
Seahawks thing looks so good yesterday
now Russell looks hurt might not play
next game but they want a Super Bowl so
it's like over Richard um you know
obviously vine had its moment of
attention that's also one of the reasons
you know one of the fun things about
creating video at scale as I have three
screens on me right now it'd be so fun
to look at me doing this in 1996 seven
eight nine 2000 2001 email or Google
AdWords there's a lot of predictions
that are right there's also things that
were 100% right that get outdated that
attention of that demo and vine is
clearly right now on Instagram stories
and snapchat stories so I think those
two places completely dominate I also
think there's some kind of old-school
places and here's a funny old school
places I'm a big fan of people getting
into some of these Facebook communities
right these private pages and I you know
with other filmmakers or Hollywood types
or what have you so I Facebook groups is
an interesting little hack I think it's
just all work look it's all very basic
I always layer the current state of the
market on top of my general thesis which
is where's the attention of the people
that you're trying to
and then how do you figure out to be
creative on it and so obviously if
everybody's listening to soundcloud but
you can't be creative and audio you're
not going to be as successful as you are
in creating long-form video long-form
video of great quality on on Vimeo is
going to be a different opportunity for
some of the filmmaker characters here
then for somebody like me who it's pert
like why do you think I've done well
like I do well in 30 70 90 second quick
thoughts quick you know I don't even
notice this Larry King let's link that
up actually right here this Larry King
actually for a little box up here
showing it this Larry King interview I
did it's so funny how some of my
smartest friends have been hitting me up
privately of like how great of a format
that is when it's quick and witty and
fast that's what I'm good at like so
you've got to find the medium that
you're good at and so if you're a
filmmaker
there's the Steve Steven Spielberg
filmmaker and there's the filmmaker
that's emerging today that understands
how to make it in a Vimeo in a YouTube
in an Instagram story I mean do you know
much storytelling capabilities are and
snapchat and Instagram stories there's
so much but who's great at it and it's a
totally different skill set than making
a 22 minute sitcom so the attention is
very obvious it's on Instagram it's on
snapchat it's on Facebook it's there
right it's on YouTube it's on Vimeo but
which one of those five as a filmmaker
can you really play in and what's the
different versions because there's a
very big difference between making a
forty one minute film on Vimeo and
making a great seven minute Instagram
story every day on Instagram Derek hey
Gary Derek from common man cocktails I
have some people telling me that
producing YouTube videos three times a
day is too much content and you'll
create more views by having content
produced less like once or twice a week
do you think that anticipation really
breeds additional views should I slow
down my production Derek I think there's
some truth to that I think I think about
the amount of content we put out I also
just think it comes down to how good you
are Derek there's some people that
should make zero videos in their entire
life I mean it just comes down to your
skill set right so so do do I think
having a schedule time not filling up
people's feeds or there's some you know
are there some tried-and-true things
that YouTube knows from a big data
standpoint yes I do and actually I think
we break them a lot of times because I
just want to and so I don't follow every
best practice because I don't know I
just don't energy I don't want to like
you know I don't know what else to tell
you I just want to pump out a lot of
content because I don't think of it just
as a show I think it is our you know
archived content I think in a 40 year
term not in a you know four month term
I'll be very honest with you I'm not
worried that I have 300,000 or so
subscribers and I should have a million
I just don't care there's just a lot of
people that have four million
subscribers on YouTube that are not as
happy or successful as I am that is not
the metric I think a lot of people get
caught up in just the numbers and so
there are first and foremost brother I
would tell you that you should do what
makes you the most happy now if you're
trying to make money and it's easier for
me as I make money and I'm what I need
is oxygen to do my thing if you need the
dollars following the best practices is
a good idea I just think it comes down
to you as a person I think there's art
and I think there's science I think
there's business people and there's
artists and you have to figure out what
your mix is if you're an artist and you
get excited about making three pieces of
content a day well that's good if you're
a business person and you need that show
to build up subscribers so you can sell
sponsorship tab alcohol brands you may
want to try a period of time of best
practices I'm in a really bad mood hi
Gary and team my name is Jenny a Hanson
and I'm coming at you from Utah and my
question is do you go with your passion
or do you go with what you're good at
I've been doing nails for 12 years my
grandmother did nails my aunt did nails
and there are any decent nail salons in
my area so do I open a nail salon or do
I go with my passion which is more in
consulting which can
teen salons it would be good but again
there aren't any good nail salons in the
area so what are your thoughts thanks
for the show thanks for your work
thanks Manor media Jenny thanks so much
for the question look I mean I'm a big
fan Jenny and I think you know this of
practicality awfully hard Jenny to
consult for nail salons where there are
none or there none that are good enough
that would actually pay a consultant so
I think your options are you can move
and go to LA New York Philly you know
places where they're more or you open a
salon your young lady so I think you
have time in a long career maybe you
open up one for a little while
build up some dollars some equity you
know I it's easy for me to say go move
maybe you've lived in Utah your whole
life your whole family's there
everybody's there you've got to be there
you can consult virtually you know it is
2016 technology has caught up you know
look I think you know I wrote a book in
2009 called crush it and it became it
became successful and it started a huge
debate in in my ecosystem of passion
over skills I don't think anybody can
answer that question for any of you
watching right now really I don't I
think what you need to do is deploy as
much self-awareness as possible I do
believe that's why I wrote crush it it's
why I'm thinking about writing a
follow-up to crush it right now I do
believe that there's nothing greater
than being able to do the thing you are
most passionate about and I think that
if you're blessed and you're able to
make the most money that way and I
actually think I'm in that category well
then that's like Nirvana but I do think
that a lot of people should consider oh
I am of the camp and you know what
that's the question of the day where do
you sit in this camp in the comments
let's sit on this one where do you sit
in this camp here is my theory that if
you make a hundred thirty thousand
dollars a year doing something you don't
love as much or at all versus making
eighty nine and loving it that you
should always go with B now people could
say that's easy for you to say because I
have student loans because I have all
these other headaches I have a weird
thesis that that 89 because you're so
happy and you're
only to work 18 hours a day becomes 131
over time and 130 becomes fired or flat
forever I really do believe that passion
works out that way and I'm not a secret
I'm not Oprah I'm not like sunshine and
rainbows not a [ __ ] Jets miss an
extra point and lose by one point
I'm just think it's practical I just
think being happy brings a better energy
in a work ethic listen I don't know if
you've heard I believe in work and I
believe the easiest way to work is to
[ __ ] love it and so you know I think
Jenny you should go with your passion I
just don't think that it's practical for
everybody I think a lot of people's
passion is to become the biggest rapper
in the world I think a lot of people's
passions to become a supermodel I think
a lot of people's passion is to become a
professional athlete or the next great
director or listed out I think people
are completely tone-deaf to their actual
skill sets and they make up ludicrous
unachievable goals which then means the
blueprint is broken from the get which
means they have no shot at victory
so I think if your passion is to be the
greatest rap in the world you should
deploy some self-awareness around maybe
your passion should be being around the
greatest rappers in the world if you
have no flow you know so anyway I don't
know I think there's a lot of things
Jenny I think self-awareness I think
recognizing you only live once I
realizing how much regret is poison and
just really and really uh-uh
Jenny I'll give you a really good answer
try your passion I'll give everybody
good answer try to pass him for two
years what's going to happen your debts
gonna compound it's not the end of the
world I mean so you can always get
practical you can always get practical
sit good ask the question just lost
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]